hello everybody and welcome back to
let's play limbo all right we're gonna
need to get the box again I have a
feeling I got a feeling that this box is
gonna help me out here because I'm gonna
put this box up there and I am going to
put it up there and I'm gonna go up and
I am going to be golden because I'm
gonna i'm going to jump jump across bunk
oh yeah can't shoot me mr. gun
Oh didn't hurt damage up across ahh this
tote it oh yeah
and whoo what's Distin okay a box oh
it's a box and then I oh and oh I get it
okay well I know hi girl
like that I I need to launch it like
give it time yep ah damn it I totally
bought that one up not an eye yes I did
I got it okay huh
ramming speed oh oh damn it
I was berry the first time yeah oh yeah
yeah oh yeah oh yeah oh yeah on aren't
from great oh crap wait no it's been
fine it's fine cuz I do this and then I
get up there's a ramp oh yeah oh yeah ah
don't kill me go kill it oh my god
everything's trying to kill me in this
game how dare it can't you me dick oh oh
oh and then when I flippy-floppy up here
whoa the box comes there burn their box
over here and I'll have this box right
here ready to go up and I got to be
quick I got to be quick about it when
I'm all done job jump i jumping and then
when i'm quick i flippy-floppy upside
down again right side up rather and then
i go on a merry way
here's my box it's my box I'm going to
booty box I bish you have mushi like how
does this thing how are these things
flipping gravity upside down that's what
I want to know that's what I want to
know it makes no sense okay so I gotta
give myself the most time so it's got to
be like just as its opening ha ya got it
all nailed it nailed it nailed it
I gather oh yeah oh whoa I need Bing
Bing Bing Bing
okay yes yes I did it guys you believed
in me right you believed that I could do
it
you believed what is it
well that's cool
okay some sort of magnet maybe if I oh
maybe if I pull this thing over here up
that's wrong
get up there boom okeydoke can a climber
can I climb it no I cannot
okay that does almost nothing pink Oh
boom
can I do for you I'm so strong nope okay
no I'm a big wimp that does nothing what
what what what
this doesn't make any sense what what I
what no yes I I don't know I I I'm I'm
at a loss maybe there's some way to get
the boxes back but I don't think so
I don't think so
it's literally this magnet like does
nothing
think ah what oh that's what it do
oh they don't think it'd be like it is
but it do oh that's magnet on the top Oh
so I gotta get ice gotta somehow get
that one to stick and this one to not oh
yeah okay they fall at different rates
so ah I got I turn the magnet on and
they rise at different rates so I got
turn it off just as soon as this one hit
yeah oh yeah oh okay there we go
that was moderately okay nothing there
nothing
ain't nothing nothing nothing
oh ah puzzle love me puzzle
what's this done
womp okie-dokie whoa
oh wow ah gimme gimme gimme no I know I
gotta hit it just as it's almost there
so that momentum lets it ride up ah
oh yeah so smart Oh gimme yeah oh yeah
ha
oh yeah wait we seem to be going through
the set pieces again we just went
through the forest we started out in
force
we're now on rooftops where we went from
course to route some i think we're
repeating set pieces oh bike yeah we are
we totally are that's the H oh god aah
oh no aah I jump oh my god I cup ha ha I
couldn't jump
I couldn't yump yump was changed yeah
yeah oh boy oh no oh no okay yup need
your turn you're so wait wait a little
more then I yup oh ah yeah oh yeah oh
there's a swinging give it away ah ah
alright I wait
and then I young ah okay maybe I just go
for it ah yup on you
I missed it completely oh my legs went
through my pelvis ah ah yup yup I jump
again okay I can jump down there and
then jump to the string yo-yo ah there
we are
oh yeah and I lower myself gently down
down to the oh we're totally we're
totally going through set pieces we make
it in getting close to the end here
woosh whew point whoo oh yeah
whoops hello hello box oh oh no oh no oh
crap
ow my pelvis has been shattered into ten
billion pieces YUM whoop flip jump jump
jump then I push you a little bit can I
come back and not wait could push it
again her boo go go oh no oh no this
better get that oh my god I'm not gonna
make am I gonna make oh why why I gotta
put I gotta do three times
boink first time
big girl up on you what didn't in our
weight in den I look wait there we go
Oh push you abuse you over there now
wait again I'm gonna make it
yeah boy here we go should be last one
and then I up on you jump again and I go
pop ah yes ah whip and Oh got that
nailed it nailed it ah no don't shoot me
ah what up so it's just alternating
ah ah come on right in the nards
right in the nards why you gotta be
right in the nards ah whoa miss me ah
double whammy okay come on come on come
on come on woosh
let me up thank you wait what what what
what I what what okay
get me up get me up give me up please
please oh my goodness huh hate it hate
it oh boy
hi timing things like this
if I'm hanging off do it up it did I
can't fall all the way or else I'll die
so I gotta do it just a time so I go
upside down again oh that's bad
is that the best bad Oh bad ah yeh Oh
just ride it ride it down oh please
don't act late aw crap
I made it okey-dokey we're gonna make it
Oh
cuz there's a little light on that
little tree no no no no oh come on can't
hear that there's an audio clue that
tells me when it's gonna do it huh
flip oh this is good no good no good no
good no good no good no good no good I
know I know
oh damn it ha oh yeah oh what wah wah
what
Oh
my methods on
okay I don't know what that was but that
was crazy awesome that was like
ridiculously sweet I think I think the
ending is like right next but we're
right out of time so I'm gonna cut it
here and get ready for what might be the
ending in the next episode though thank
you everybody for watching and as always
I will see you in the next part but I